[Musik]
gold entstand vor milliarden von jahren
im all noch vor der entstehung unseres
sonnensystems
spätere meteoriteneinschläge bringen das
gold auf die erde dass menschen seit
mehr als 6000 jahren abbauen es ist
nahezu unzerstörbar es rostet nicht und
es läuft auch nicht an gold behält stets
seinen magischen glanz es ist so weich
dass es zu feinst und schmuck geformt
werden kann und es lässt sich stärker
denen als jedes andere metalle
um den äquator mit einem gold faden zu
umspannen braucht man nur 12,5 kilogramm
gold weil es den elektrischen strom gut
leitet bis gold auch als bauteil in
smartphones gefragt nicht umsonst also
gilt gold als das element das verbindet
[Musik]
gold ist eines der seltensten
materialien auf erden je stärker die
nachfrage desto größer wird der aufwand
für die förderung
um nur eine einzige feinunze gold zu
schürfen muss man derzeit rund 800 euro
bezahlen rund zwei drittel des gesamten
jemals geförderten gold bestandes wurde
erst nach 1950 gewonnen
heute liegt der gesamte bisher abgebaute
welt goldbestand bei rund 200.000 tonnen
lässt man die gleiche menge gold zu
einem würfel beträgt dessen kantenlänge
rund 20 meter
wäre alles gold der welt zu gleichen
teilen verteilten würde jeder mensch
knapp eine un- zu bekommen
[Musik]
während des goldstandards ende des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts wurden münzen
und banknoten durch goldreserven des
jeweiligen landes gedeckt und konnten zu
einem festen kursen getauscht werden
diese proportionalität gerät aus zwei
gründen allerdings schnell aus den fugen
zum einen wurde in kriegs- phasen
wesentlich mehr geld gedruckt als durch
gold gedeckt wurde um die immensen
kriegs ausgaben zu decken zum anderen
wurde immer mehr viral geld auf buchgeld
genannt benutzt dazu zählen schecks und
überweisungen aber auch die gigantischen
summen die von zentralbanken an
privatbanken geliehen werden dieses
ungleichgewicht führte aufgrund hoher
inflation nicht nur zum zusammenbruch
des goldstandards in vielen
industrieländern sondern auch dazu dass
bargeld wie wir es heute kennen fast
keinen materiellen wert mehr hat
winter wird von stahel tief im keller
der bundesbank lagert ein teil des
deutschen goldes der aktuelle wert liegt
bei 107 5 milliarden euro es ist die
eiserne reserve für schlechte zeiten
gold bestimmte sind ein vertrauensanker
vertrauen in die währung weil sich für
die werthaltigkeit und zur bilanz stehen
der deutsche golf staat hat sich vor
allem während des wirtschaftswunders
angesammelt als deutschland
exportweltmeister wurde
handelsüberschüsse wurden damals in
deutschland mit gold verrechnet und der
deutsche goldberg wuchs außer in
frankfurt wurde das gold auch an den
internationalen handelsplätzen in new
york london und paris eingelagert muss
in krisenzeiten schnell und andere
währungen tauschen zu können so lagern
bisher 69 prozent des deutschen goldes
im ausland und nur 31 in frankfurt
zukünftig sollen es 50 sein dass gold
lager in paris wird ganz aufgelöst dann
in paris in frankreich genau die gleiche
wie haben sie es auch hier in frankfurt
in deutschland gibt es besteht also
gleich mehr die notwendigkeit gold in
eine andere währung zu tauschen und das
ist eben für new york nicht so der fall
ist verloren und nicht so der fall und
das sind ganz einfachen grund für die
verlagerung
die gold rückhol aktion dauerte bis 2020
dabei wurden die goldbestände gleich
überprüfbaren fühlbaren wir können also
sicher sein den goldschatz gibt es
wirklich
davon haben wir uns selbst überzeugen
dürfen und die gold kammer bei degussa
goldhandel in frankfurt besucht
chefökonom thorsten polleit führt uns
durch diese schatzkammer
wir leben in unruhigen zeiten wir haben
die kuh einer pandemie hinter uns es
heißt ja immer gold ist ein gewisser
inflationsschutz jetzt ist der goldmarkt
aber dieses jahr gefallen und die
inflation gestiegen wie passt das
eigentlich zusammen nun man muss
feststellen dass der goldpreis in den
letzten jahren stark gestiegen ist also
durchschnitt der letzten 20 jahre um
ungefähr acht prozent pro jahr und sie
haben natürlich recht am äußeren ende
ist jetzt der goldpreis etwas abgesunken
gegenüber seinen bisherigen rekordpreis
von 2 1040 dollar pro feinunze im august
2020 aber darunter verbirgt sich eben
ein langfristiger aufwärtstrend der
goldpreis verteuert sich und schützt
damit natürlich entsprechende auch gegen
inflation jetzt haben die staaten
weltweit billionen in den markt gepumpt
tatsächlich um die korona pandemie
irgendwie zu beherrschen um ihr herr der
lage zu werden hat das auswirkungen
diese schuldenproblematik auf den
goldmarkt damit ist zu rechnen derzeit
hat die amerikanische zentralbank ja
angedeutet den zins anheben zu wollen in
2023 das ist noch lange hin aber das hat
dazu geführt dass die zinsen im
kapitalmarkt leicht angestiegen sind und
das drückt in der regel kurzfristig den
goldpreis aber wenn die defizite weiter
hoch bleiben dies und jenseits des
atlantiks und immer wer immer mehr neues
geld in umlauf gebracht wird dann wirkt
das natürlich inflationär das heißt die
konsumgüter preise steigen oder auch die
vermögenspreise steigen und das wird mit
sicherheit auch den goldpreis erfassen
denn letztlich reagiert der goldpreis
das zeigt die erfahrung eben auf
steigende inflation mit einem
preisauftrieb es ist ein mühsamer teurer
und im wahrsten sinne des wortes
steiniger weg um das wenige gold im
gestein zu fördern dieses gestein wird
gesprengt und zermahlen bevor irgendwann
zunächst flüssiges und dann fest dass
gold zu kostbaren barren verarbeitet
wird
herr poller das gold was ich bei ihnen
kaufen könnte zum beispiel wo kommt das
eigentlich her und woran erkenne ich
dass wir kennen das alle aus dem
hollywoodfilm vielleicht von früher dass
auf gold gebissen wird noch echtes wie
macht man das heute es gibt einen
internationalen goldmarkt dort wird
physische ware gehandelt zwischen banken
aber auch scheideanstalten und
goldhändler sind teilnehmer dieses
internationalen goldmarktes und das gold
muss natürlich überprüft werden und das
können letztlich nur fachleute also
ausgebildete goldschmiede die sind dann
in der lage zu testieren dabei ein
goldstück die entsprechende qualität hat
hat ob ein barren ein entsprechendes
gewicht hat der feingehalt stimmt also
da muss man sich an einen fachmann
wenden an einen vertrauensvollen
fachmann herbst wenn ich so bei ihnen
raus höhere ein bisschen gold schadet
keinem im depot aber ich meine ich habe
jetzt das problem wo lagere ich das
ganze unter das kopfkissen mache ich es
in tresor wir hatten tresor zu hause
also was mache ich mit meinem goldbarren
oder goldmünzen also ich stimme zu
zunächst einen teil seines vermögens
sollte man auch in form von gold halten
in form von physischen gold also barren
oder münzen und das gold kann man lagern
in sicherheits depots man kann
schließfächer anmieten dafür gibt es
einen markt da ist es dann sicher
verwahrt man bekommt ein schlüssel und
hat dann entsprechend auch nur zugriff
als person auf dieses bach und ich hab
noch einen kleinen tipp für den
hausgebrauch
schön handlich und unglaublich nützlich
nicht so schwer aber
extrem sinnvoll dieser goldbarren dass
nämlich ein flaschenöffner
nur sechs länder weltweit teilen sich
die größten bekannten goldreserven am
boden sie bestreiten rund die hälfte der
jährlichen gold fördermenge der mit
abstand größte goldproduzent ist china
[Musik]
danach
folgt australien
dahinter russland die usa und
kanada
[Musik]
südamerika ist auf 15 zurückgefallen
aber auch bei uns gibt es nachweislich
noch gold vorkommen zum beispiel an der
elbe und dem rhein oder in bayern an der
isar und den inn
[Musik]
weshalb ist gold im alltag so selten
sichtbar
schätzungsweise rund 20 prozent des welt
galt bestandes ruhen als nationale
goldreserve in den tresoren der
zentralbanken
weitere 20 lagern als investment in den
tresoren von privatanlegern in form von
barren und münzen
und die hälfte des weltweiten bestandes
bis zu schmuck verarbeitet
[Musik]
und das restliche gold verrichtet als
bauteil technischer produkte unbemerkt
seinen dienst
bevor wir die korona pandemie hatten
hatten wir uns viele jahre tatsächlich
mit der euro krise beschäftigt und da
hörte man von einzelnen staaten ja auch
dass sie überlegt haben zumindest an die
goldreserven zu gehen können sie dazu
vielleicht noch einiges erzählen es gab
tatsächlich eine zeit in den 1990 er
jahren haben einige zentralbanken ihre
goldreserven verkauft dieser prozess ist
aber längst zu ende gegangen und
mittlerweile sieht man weltweit dass
insbesondere die großen zentralbanken
der aufstrebenden volkswirtschaften also
china russland indien türkei
nettokäufer am physischen goldmarkt sind
und die vereinigten staaten von amerika
die größte volkswirtschaft der welt ist
auch gleichzeitig der größten
goldbesitzer mit mehr als 8000 tonnen
und auf platz zwei die bundesrepublik
deutschland mit immerhin 3400 tonnen wo
lauern denn vielleicht so psychologische
fallen wenn es um den goldkauf geht da
muss man aufpassen gold ist eine
versicherung sie schützt gegen inflation
und zahlungsausfälle im finanzsystem und
man sollte gold kaufen wenn die zeiten
ruhig sind und nicht warten bis die
krise
ausgebrochen ist denn dann ist der
goldpreis gestiegen und meist zu teuer
und man sollte eben auch mit einem
langfristigen horizont gold kaufen also
wert einen anlagehorizont von drei oder
fünf oder mehr jahren hat der ist gerade
aktuell gut beraten physisches gold zu
kaufen ja und das ist jetzt tatsächlich
ein echter goldbarren ein kilo schwer
und
das thema nachhaltigkeit spielt ja
überall eine immer größere rolle herr
polleit wie sieht es eigentlich beim
thema gold mit der nachhaltigkeit aus ja
da werden international große
anstrengungen unternommen beispielsweise
bei der förderung umwelt standards
einzuhalten es gibt mittlerweile
verfahren die erlauben umwelt schont das
gold herauszulösen aus dem gestein und
insbesondere schreiben wie bei bewusster
sehr sehr groß dass durch cycling also
das bedienen der goldnachfrage durch das
vorhandene goldangebot denn das
verhindert dass gewissermaßen neue
umwelt ressourcen eingesetzt werden
müssen um neues gold aus der erde zu
fördern
fragen wir einen der sich vom schein des
goldes nicht blenden lässt joachim
goldberg
wirtschaftspsychologe und
finanzmarktanalyst
in krisenzeiten setzen ja auch manche
menschen ganz traditionell auf gold das
ist etwas haptisches tat man was in der
hand man denkt man lebt es sich in den
tresor goldbarren oder goldschmuck wir
sind hier auf der goethestraße in
frankfurt hier sind die auslagen voller
gold und geld sozusagen was halten sie
von dem gold als anlage naja das ist
immer so eine sache ist die frage was
wollen sie haben was wollen sie bekommen
wollen die sicherheit bekommen für den
krisenfall oder wollen sie gold anlegen
um damit eine rendite zu erzielen und
wenn es um die rendite geht dann wird es
natürlich ein bisschen schwierig ich
denk mal an mein leben mit ihr zurück an
meinen börsianer beziehungsweise
devisenhändler leben da gehe ich ins
jahr 1979 zurück wo ich angefangen habe
und damals war gold pro unze bei 220
dollar der standard & poor's 500 index
der breit gestreute us index war bei 100
gewesen gold ist heute bei 1.800 dollar
beinahe und der set index bei
4.400 bei 4222 punkten auch wenn gold in
diesem jahr den rückwärtsgang wieder
eingelegt hat warum setzen dennoch
anleger zum teil auf gold und warum
setzen starten auch auf gold ja es ist
eine beimischung ich ein start der gold
in seinen reserven stehen hat der hat
natürlich letztlich verkörpert er das ja
eine gewisse sicherheit ja und die
menschen glauben halt immer noch eine
währung die mit gold hinterlegt sei es
eine gute währung obwohl die geschichte
auch ganz andere dinge gelehrt hat herr
goldberg wann würden sie denn sagen ist
gold tatsächlich eine sichere bank naja
wenn beispielsweise das geldsystem
zerbricht aber wollen es ist tatsächlich
die ganze zeit darauf setzen dass
irgendetwas kaputt geht es macht nicht
glücklich vielen dank herr goldberg wir
haben jetzt schon viel über gold gehört
aber nicht nur gold fasziniert die
menschen seit jahrtausenden schauen
sondern auch diamanten und edelsteine
und darüber hören wir jetzt was sind wir
doch mal ehrlich und unromantisch
diamanten sind nichts weiter als
zusammen gepresster kohlenstoff und der
ist unglaublich hart diamanten
zerschneiden mühelos marmor oder granit
es macht sich für werkzeuge hochkarätig
nützlich und nicht nur das ein
lichtstrahl der durch einen
diamantenring tritt auch vollständig
wieder aus grund für aufwendige schliffe
die lassen das licht einzigartig funkeln
diamanten bilden sich im erdmantel in
mindestens 150 kilometern tiefe unter
großem druck und hoher temperatur
vulkanische schlote holen sie mit magma
dann an die oberfläche
das gestein rund um solche schlote wird
deshalb schichtweise durchsucht seit
einigen jahren bleibt die weltproduktion
natur diamanten relativ konstant die
drei größten förderländer sind groß land
botswana und der kongo doch sie werden
auch illegal geschürft sogenannte
blutdiamanten werden aus
konfliktregionen geschmuggelt um kriege
zu finanzieren
den handel damit soll seit 2003 der
internationale kimberley-prozess
eindämmen mit herkunfts zertifikate für
jeden stein übrigens das gewichts maß
für edelsteine stammt aus dem altertum
zum wiegen kleiner mengen wurden
samenkörner des johannesburg baumes
benutzt sie sind meist gleich groß und
prokon etwa 200 milligramm schwer das
gewicht des heutigen karas ganze
3107 karat brachte 1905 der größte je
gefundene rohdiamant auf die waage
es ist weit mehr als über ein halbes
kilo über 100 schmuckstücke wurden aus
ihm gefertigt und die neuen größten sind
heute die funkelnde pracht der
britischen kronjuwelen
goldberg nicht nur gold fasziniert die
menschen schon seit urzeiten sondern
eben auch diamanten was halten sie davon
diamanten sind besser zu transportieren
leichter zu transportieren aber es gibt
dann doch einige überraschungen
meinem bekanntenkreis ist es passiert da
hat jemand einen diamanten geerbt da gab
es ein zertifikat dazu 10.000 dmax
sollte der wert sein hat sie nicht viel
aus diamanten gemacht wollte ihn
verkaufen und da hat man 500 euro
geboten das sind die enttäuschung wie
das leben manchmal so mit sich bringt
[Musik]
jetzt haben wir heute tatsächlich sehr
viel über gold erfahren doch wir haben
auch gelernt ist es nicht alles gold was
glänzt und ich versuche jetzt zum
schluss mal meinen eigenen goldbarren zu
gießen
[Musik]
zwölf kilo schwer und
ich krieg in komm raus schwer unhandlich
und gut gesichert
[Musik]